(crowd cheering)
- Have y'all ever played together?
Have you ever played with Sheila?
- I didn't realize that's who I was
in the makeup room with.
- Oh my gosh.
I should've been like, you
wanna come out and play with us?
I didn't even think of
that, but I was like,
man, y'all would sound incredible.
You're both such amazing
musicians and artists. Yeah.
- Would've just held her
sticks till she needed 'em.
- Oh my God. She is incredible.
But I have to ask you, first
of all, this is amazing.
- Thank you.
- I'm gonna steal it.
But did you just go to
Japan with your son?
- I did.
- I love Japan.
- [Kelly] Did you have such a good time?
- You know, I've been there
before, probably like you,
but I've never gotten
to see or look around.
'cause we sing
- We're working.
- We do interviews all day.
So I went for pure vacation.
We had the best time.
- Yeah. First of all, the
strawberry blonde is so your vibe.
- Thank you. Thank you.
- Yeah. I have to compliment it.
So your son, my kids, they
asked, they're 7 and 9,
but they asked to come on stage with me.
Did your son, 'cause I
know that he plays with you
sometimes on stage, right? He's 12, right?
- Yeah. He plays some drums
and he asked to come out on tour with me
and we had practiced really good.
And then he went to his
dad's for two weeks in Texas
and he got out and we
show up to soundcheck
and y'all, he wasn't good.
You were just here. Oh look!
- You're like, oh bud, did
you take some time off?
- Well, it was my fault
'cause I didn't rehearse
with him prior to soundcheck.
And so it was one of those
weird moments as a mom
where you're like, ooh, how do
I break the news? This isn't.
- Yeah. But be honest.
'cause you know, it's like you'd rather,
I mean, my mother wasn't mean.
It's like, you gotta be
honest with your kids.
That way they don't go
out there and do something
and they're like, mom,
why didn't you tell me?
- Exactly.
- Yeah. He had a moment though. Right?
So it didn't work out.
But then he kind of went to the bathroom
and did you overhear
him talking to himself?
Is that what you?
- Yeah, so I told him, I was
like, you know, first of all,
I should have practiced
with you before today
and you're not quite ready for tonight,
but we can practice before tonight
and if you get there we can do it.
And if not, we have months on tour.
And he's like, no, I wanna
practice. I wanna try.
And I was like, all right.
So we start practicing
and he misses his entrance.
We do it again, misses his entrance,
do it again, misses his entrance.
And he's like, it's cool.
It's cool. I'll be right back.
And he goes into the bathroom
and he shuts the door
and I hear him go
"Here I am, crying in the
bathroom. (crowd laughs)
And I know I'm not supposed to be crying
'cause it's okay to make mistakes
but it doesn't feel very good."
And then it gets quiet for a
minute. And then he's like,
"Well," and then he opens the door
and I run back to the bed.
I'm like, cool, cool. Everything
cool? What's going on?
And he's like, let's do it again.
And we kept practicing.
He practiced for a long time
and he got it to where
I was like, if you want,
you can try it tonight.
So he walked out there
and he just crushed it.
It was pretty cool.
- I love that. (crowd applauding)
Did you teach him that
kind of emotional maturity?
Because that's pretty mature
for a 12 year old kid.
Just to walk in there and
walk yourself through it.
- The best thing I think for me as a mom
has just been learning to
heal and heal my own self.
And it's made me a much
more available mom.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Amen.
- And I know so much more
now than I was taught.
And so yeah, teaching him emotional tools,
learning how to label the right feeling.
Because a lot of us,
I don't know if y'all,
I grew up with emotional dyslexia.
I was like, not treated very nice.
And it was like, I love you.
It's the wrong word for those things.
You know, so you kind
of match miss feelings.
- Because you're like,
what does love mean?
- I'm gonna go get in some
bad relationships for a while.
Figure it out.
- I don't know what you speak of.
Okay. So, you toured with your parents,
which I didn't know that.
Both were musicians.
So you toured at a very young age, right?
- Yeah, I started touring with them.
I started singing with them
at 5 in hotels for tourists.
And then we would tour
Alaska Native villages,
Inuit villages, all through
like the Arctic Circle.
- That's cool.
- Yeah. So we get dropped
off on a plane on skis
and then a dog sled would pick us up.
That was our transpo. We,
- This is not normal.
- No. We would stay in a
cabin with like a host family.
And I remember being given
a barbecued moose leg,
it was like this long. And I was like,
- You're like, how do you approach it?
How do you think you go in on that?
- Full caveman with it.
- A little bigger than a
drumstick. That's amazing.
So You're Not Alone Challenge,
let's talk about, we
talked about this before.
But it came back around this year.
So it's again happening. What
do you wanna tell people?
What if they haven't heard
of Not Alone Challenge?
- Last year was our first time doing the
#notalonechallenge.
You guys helped me debut.
- [Kelly] On the show.
- And thanks to you guys, we became
the biggest social media
campaign for mental health.
- I don't think it was us,
but I think maybe you had
a lot to do with that.
- I think you had a huge
bit of to do with that.
We reached one and a half
billion eyeballs last year.
- What?
- And it really shows
I think the importance
and the need of social anxiety.
Of different mental health issues.
And it's really important
to raise awareness.
But what we really wanna
do with this challenge
is make sure we're putting
tools into people's hands.
'cause we're about
500,000 therapists short
currently in America.
And there's lots of tools
that work like CBT and DBT
or learning how to meditate
in different tools.
There's a lot of people that live in
what I call a mental health desert
where they just don't
have access or money.
And that's unacceptable.
One in four kids right now
are having suicidal ideation.
That's not a number we
intend to live with.
We can really do something about that.
- Absolutely, oh my God.
- Yeah. So we're doing auction
items if people wanna see,
I mean, last year Billie Eilish
did an incredible package.
All sorts of athletes, if they go to
NotAloneChallenge.org,
they can see what to.
- I was gonna say, how
else can people help?
Is that the thing? Bidding on things.
- Yeah, bidding on things
really helps. That raises money.
The Foundation Reserves Social
Club is actually gonna match
donations up to a million dollars.
So every dollar y'all give
really, really counts.
And this is again, empowering,
especially at-risk youth
to have mental health help.
- Absolutely. Which is our future.
(crowd cheering)
This year marks the 25th anniversary
of her multi-platinum album
Spirit, which is incredible.
So this was your second album, right?
- Yeah.
- Did you have that sophomore
pressure? Did you feel it?
- Oh my god.
Everybody put that pressure on you.
I wouldn't have known
about the sophomore slump.
And you're like, well,
thanks for telling me. Geez.
- I know people do tell you, why?
- I don't know. But it
was one of those things
I really had to contend with.
Like my first album, I
wrote it not meaning to,
I just wrote. And my first hit,
Who Will Save Your Soul is
the first song I ever wrote.
I didn't mean to write it.
And I didn't mean to write
a hit. So it was weird
to be like, how do I now try to do this?
- Well, it was also very
different. Like your sound
is very different and
it was very different
from anything out.
So I thought that was really cool.
That's why you probably didn't think, oh,
I don't know if the masses are gonna.
But boy. Did we ever.
Everybody leaned in on that.
- That's so nice. I know.
And that was the thing that
really saved me was I had read,
I got discovered when I was homeless,
and I'd read a book about
the music business called
Everything You Need To Know
About the Music Business.
I got it at the library.
And I read about contracts and royalties
and mechanicals and advances.
And so I turned down my advance.
I turned down a million
dollars as a homeless kid
and I took the biggest backend
anybody had ever been given
because I didn't think a
folk record would sell.
But if it did sell, I would get rewarded.
- You are the smartest person alive.
- And I had a clause in it for
every million albums I sold,
I would go up by points.
I sold 15 million albums
on that first album.
- Oh my God.
- It's insane.
- So basically you didn't
have to work again.
You didn't have to work again.
- And I never cared about
fame. I never cared about hits,
you know, to write.
- But you know what you did,
you believed in yourself,
you believed in your gift.
And I think that's more,
I've turned down money too
when they ask you to do things.
And it's not, but then it also tells you,
if I'm turning down this much money,
does that not tell you something like,
you know what I'm saying?
I really don't want to do it.
Like if it's that much money,
I'm really not into that.
Like that should tell
you. But they don't care.
- I just really wanted
the artistic freedom.
And I wanted to earn it.
I didn't want to like have
this risk on the front end.
And so that was the exact attitude.
I was like, wait a minute, I just,
if I never spend my money,
if I'm really careful,
I never have to have a hit.
I don't have to do this, I get to do this.
And that's really powerful.
- And then it still stays
your passion and your love.
- Yeah.
And so I wrote another weird song
where the entire bridge was like,
in the end, only kindness matters.
The label's like, that's the whole bridge?
I'm like, yeah, that's the whole bridge.
Like, it's only all you
wanna say? I'm like, yep.
Only kindness matters.
And they're like, okay.
- It's enough. It's a really great line.
I was like, it's enough.
So wait, I have to talk to you about this
because bonus songs on
the 25th inspired by,
like this, you only got these songs.
There are songs that you
had recorded in your life,
or not recorded, but just played.
And there were fans that actually recorded
because you didn't remember them.
- Yeah.
- And you actually found a fan
you go to, is his name Allen?
- Yeah.
- This is the most incredible
story. Tell everybody.
- So I've always been prolific,
but I've never written anything down.
And so I lose songs all the time.
And so it was the dawn of the internet.
And so I'd get on there on some listserv.
I'd be like, does anybody
have a song called Jessica
that I sang once at a cafe in Toronto?
And this guy would always write back
and go, yeah, I have that bootleg.
And yes, I have that one.
I was like, do you want a
job? So I ended up hiring him.
He's worked for me since
like '94 or something.
- That's incredible.
So Jewel is definitely
a lyricist and a poet.
And so in honor of the 25th
anniversary of her album Spirit,
we wanted to go back
through some of her lyrics.
So here's the first. It's
from Hands. Beautiful.
Which is on Spirit.
My hands are small, I know
But they're not yours, they are my own,
and I am never broken. It's so simple.
Like even your bridge, you
said about the kindness,
it's so simple, but that's powerful.
What made you like write
that and stick with that?
- You know, I wrote a lot of those lyrics
when I was homeless and
I was shoplifting a lot
and I was trying to teach
myself not to shoplift.
And people weren't very nice
to me at that time in my life.
- Maybe because you're shoplifting or?
- Yeah. I mean it wasn't a great,
it wasn't a great life plan for sure.
But literally that lyric
was like, these are mine.
Nobody's making me steal.
I'm choosing to do this
even though I'm homeless,
even though I have no money,
even though I have no food,
this is still my choice
and I can do better.
And I'm not broken,
but it really came from
this feeling of ownership.
I thought it was, yeah, exactly.
- Yeah. I love that. I
didn't mean to make the joke,
but I had to go there.
Okay, so wait, one more.
This is from Intuition and this
is off Jewel's fifth album.
So follow your heart, your intuition,
it will lead you in the right direction.
Let go of your mind. Your
intuition is easy to find.
Just follow your heart, baby.
- I feel like the choruses
are never the poetic part,
actually now that I'm looking at them.
For me, that song was, I
wanted to write a pop album.
And it's very, very
hard to write a pop hit
without talking about love.
And I counted how many
times it's been done
and it's very, very few.
And so I challenged myself
to write a pop song,
- Unless you're hating on it.
- Yeah. I guess that's, yeah. Same thing.
- Because that's my catalog. Yeah.
- Good catalog, it's been working.
- So you got a theme.
- Yeah. So for me it was
like, how do I write a song
that's not about love?
That's about like
following your instincts.
So that was why I wrote it.
- I love that. So the
25th anniversary edition
of Jewel's multi-platinum
sophomore album Spirit
is out November 17th.
And go online to learn more
about her second annual
Not Alone Challenge and
how you can participate
and also how you can
just get some information
if you need some.